[Applauso]
[Musica]
[Risate]
sì
[Musica]
[Applauso]
questa storia comincia con un giovane
ascolano chiama titolo zilioli ama
scalare le montagne insieme ai suoi
amici
loro sono i padri dell'alpinismo
ascolano io nel terreno scrittore
alpinista francese
definisce gli alpinisti
conquistatori dell'inutile perché in
effetti fanno qualcosa di perfettamente
inutile
e l'inutile è importantissimo perché
serve a portare bellezza nelle nostre
vite e la montagna e bellezza e anche
pericolo è
un alpinista come tito questo lo sa e lo
accetta
30 marzo del 1958
tito zilioli perde la vita durante una
scalata sul monte vettore la cima più
alta dei monti sibillini
pensate quanto incomprensibile possa
essere la morte
fingevano di 24 anni sulla montagna in
una città di provincia come ascoli che è
lontana dalla scena
alpinistica quella dei grandi scalatori
eppure zilioli il nome di una famiglia
colpita da un lutto terribile
diventa anche il nome di un legame
speciale tra la città e la montagna
perché accadono delle cose che si
mettono in fila come sempre quando c'è
una storia che vuole andare da qualche
parte
l'antica comunanza agraria di pretare
che è un paesino ai piedi del monte
vettore nel comune di arquata del tronto
dona la sezione cari ascoli a cui titolo
zilioli era iscritto un fazzoletto di
terra perché sulla montagna si
costruisca un piccolo rifugio per
ricordare il giovane alpinista caduto e
anche per avvicinare persone monti
sibillini
ad ascoli piceno si costituisce un
comitato e ne fanno parte gli amici
alpini amanti della montagna guide e
raccolgono i fondi che servono per
costruire il rifugio zilioli con cui
fondi verranno pagati i mastri muratori
arquata ni che lavoreranno un'intera
estate sulla montagna
dormendo sotto una tenda e trasportando
il materiale a dorso di mulo perché non
hanno ancora a disposizione un
elicottero
e così alla fine sulla montagna cioè
questa piccola sentinella in pietra che
per tanto tempo offre riparo agli
escursionisti agli alpinisti a chi si è
perso nella nebbia a chi si e
infreddolito in un vento che lassù tira
molto forte ai soccorritori che vanno a
recuperare gli infortunati
noi lo chiamiamo affettuosamente
rifugio in realtà un bivacco chi va in
montagna ben presente la differenza
perché in un rifugio troviamo un gestore
che ci prepara un piatto di polenta una
bevanda calda se andiamo in un bivacco
dobbiamo portare con noi tutto quello
che ci serve per pernottare per
bivaccare
il 24 agosto del 2016
un terremoto sconvolge il centro italia
strappa via dall'appennino paesi vite
memorie e si prende anche il piccolo
rifugio zilioli che resta in piedi
quella notte terribile del 24 agosto e
resta in piedi per proteggere i ragazzi
scout che dormono nel suo interno
resterà in piedi anche dopo con le
scosse anche più violente però ormai è
un involucro
distrutto inutile vuoto the stalli in
attesa di crollare su se stesso e questa
potrebbe essere la fine
della storia dei rifugio zilioli
questa storia però non ha nessuna
intenzione di terminare sotto un mucchio
di sassi caduti e così si rimette in
cammino per tornare da qualche parte è
di nuovo a distanza di 60 anni si ripete
questo abbraccio tra la città e le
montagna enti si mettono insieme per
mettere insieme le risorse della
ricostruzione del rifugio zilioli sono
enti che si occupano da sempre di dare
sostegno e territorio e la fondazione
carisap l'avis provinciale di ascoli
piceno c'è la società tennisti
tridentini del club alpino italiano ci
sono altri soggetti privati che vogliono
contribuire anche loro tra questi c'è la
famiglia il titolo zilioli tante persone
si mettono insieme sono volontari sono i
soci cai i soccorritori che passano fine
settimana sulla montagna a vigilare sul
cantiere sono professionisti che
lavorano in modo del tutto gratuito come
il progettista architetto valeriano
vallesi sono vigili del fuoco di pescara
che ci donano uno dei voli di elicottero
che ci sono necessari per trasportare il
materiale e così alla fine
il piccolo zilio di nuovo al suo posto
questa volta ha un'anima al legno
involucro in metallo linee contemporanee
che però ricordano la sagoma del vecchio
rifugio sorge sulle spalle in pietra del
vecchio rifugio che questa volta
sostengono anche un bellissimo un
terrazzo panoramico che prima non c'era
da cui lo sguardo ammira
interminati spazi e sovrumani silenzi
davanti a un bar e in cui naufragare e
dolce perché qui siamo venuti azzurri
celebrati da giacomo leopardi
questi tre minuti di video che abbiamo
visto condensano tre mesi faticosi
ansiosi pieni quasi ogni giorno di un
problema da risolvere una decisione da
prendere a volte anche un emergenza
eppure sono stati tre mesi straordinari
esaltanti perché abbiamo lavorato
insieme fianco a fianco
marchigiani trentini abruzzesi umbri e
alla fine sentiamo di aver fatto
qualcosa di più per ricostruire un'opera
edilizia la montagna abbiamo restituito
abbiamo restituito
accoglienza riparo al popolo della
montagna abbiamo restituito
sostegno all'economia dei paesi della
montagna abbiamo restituito ritorno al
nostro appennino
che l'albero che attraverso il nostro
paese da un albero che è vivo e forte se
sono vive e forti le comunità che vivono
e lavorano in appennino sono quelle le
comunità che si prendono cura di un bene
comune importante come la nostra
montagna e lo fanno anche per noi che
viviamo e lavoriamo in città e anche noi
possiamo essere parte di quella comunità
se viviamo il territorio lo amiamo lo e
frequentiamo nel modo giusto
accompagniamo altri a farlo che è quello
che fa club alpino italiano anche
attraverso i suoi rifugi e bivacchi
ecco io credo che alla fine ricostruendo
lo ziò lì noi abbiamo ritenuto questo
legame che il sisma voleva lacerare ci
siamo ripresi un pezzo di identità e lo
abbiamo rimesso al suo posto nel cuore
dell'appennino
e facendo questo
dopo le pagine brutte del sisma
terribili e della pandemia io credo che
forse abbiamo anche capito una cosa
importante identità non è un pezzo di
carta e in qualunque luogo in cui la
coscienza la vita il futuro mettono
radici grazie
[Applauso]